he might have lost the election
but donald trump never went away
despite his poor record as president
multiple legal investigations and the
fact he tried to overturn the result in
2020 trump's grip on the republican
party seems to be strengthening
in august 2022 the republicans most
ardent trump critic liz cheney was
beaten by a trump endorsed candidate in
a republican primary election
could america be facing a second term
for president trump
i think he wants to be president again
absolutely i think he loved being
president and he would love to have the
legal protections of being president
again
he loves the politics he loves the
crowds he loves um he loves the fight he
feeds on it
and
um
and fundamentally i mean he loves the
attention and i think he's even more
likely to run now that um we've seen
this federal investigation get stepped
up in recent days
i think the deeper his legal jeopardy
the more likely it is that he will run
he'll be able to present himself as as a
victim
and run on the politics of grievance
more easily if he's if he's being
prosecuted he'll also
be able to
make the argument that
even more forcefully i think that these
um prosecutions are partisan
attempts to prevent him from returning
to the white house and so in that sense
running could help him with his legal
strategy uh at the same time that legal
problem could help him with his
political strategy there is a hard core
of the republican party that's desperate
for him to be the candidate and you see
their trump flags still flying
from their homes and from their boats
[Applause]
i don't think that if most republican
office holders
and even candidates around the country
were to speak uh
really candidly about it that most of
them
would want him to run again i think a
lot of the republican party is is ready
to to turn the page the just all the
craziness the distractions the even the
cult of personality itself
i think they're tired of it and there is
a um
another generation of of republican
candidates kind of waiting
impatiently in the wings but any of them
would have a very hard time overcoming
the advantage that donald trump begins
with critical primaries overnight in
wyoming and alaska with a crushing
defeat for liz cheney at the hands of
her trump-backed opponent liz cheney's
defeat didn't really come as a surprise
to anybody at least of all to her i
think she'd been expecting it
she has been the strongest voice
against him really within the republican
party it basically validates or
concretizes the idea that standing up to
donald trump spells electoral doom and i
think
liz cheney's loss will be
exhibit a
in the future for him of what happens if
you cross him the midterms are obviously
extremely important because a number of
candidates
are running particularly in senate races
in battleground states who are donald
trump's picks they were not
the party's picks and so in states where
the republicans have a real shot at
picking up a senate seat
they are now fighting kind of rearguard
action because the candidates that
they've put forward are so weak
so
if if the republicans are not able to
take the senate back as a consequence of
these essentially trump nominated
candidates
i think that will contribute to a real
sense of dissatisfaction with him with
him within the party now whether that
has any effect or not is
an entirely different question because
the reality is
donald trump's a proven loser as uh he
lost the presidency for his party he
lost the house and he lost the senate
for his party and other politicians in
the party were grinding their teeth
about this two years ago
and it hasn't stopped them from falling
into line once again now so even if uh
donald trump's chosen candidates
underperform that's not necessarily a
problem for him
when it comes to securing the republican
nomination again
i think he would struggle in a general
election
to win a majority of the votes that's
different than saying you can't be
elected president again though because
as we've seen there is a path to the
presidency that runs through
um piling up enough electoral votes and
key battleground states that could
potentially get them there again with
minority support the scariest
development in the last few years in
american politics has been the
denigration of
of the integrity of the vote republican
candidates for
key roles in counting the vote next time
around are people who have completely
bought into the so-called big lie that
that donald trump did win we may be in a
situation where
uh
he does well in these battleground
states and he has allies that he didn't
have last time in key positions
who were in a position to
falsify the results it's a dark
prospect
um
but i think we've learned you know in
the last few years that we have to take
these kinds of
scenarios very seriously because um
you know donald trump has repeatedly
broken through the boundaries of
everybody else's political imagination
if you'd like to read more of our
coverage of american politics please
click the link and please also subscribe
and thank you very much for watching
you